good morning Hank it's Sunday it's news
day and the news around here is that my
house is a construction zone and most of
the electricity is turned off and we
don't have any place to sleep and
unrelated to the incredibly expensive
home renovation my basement flooded on
Friday so now I have to take out all the
carpet and fixing it is gonna cost a
billion dollars and I'm cranky and when
I get cranky
I put Willy and his tiny elephant
costume oh hey two quick things I will
be reading and signing and hanging out
with fellow made of awesome nerdfighters
this Tuesday at a bookstore in LaGrange
Illinois and next Tuesday at the library
in Columbus Ohio both events are totally
free please come more info in the
doobly-doo and now back to your
regularly scheduled intro okay hey today
I want to talk about elephant puppies
and capitalism because capitalism has
had a bad go of it recently like failure
to regulate the free market is being
blamed for the Great Recession and for
the screwed up American healthcare
system and a lot of other things and I
happen to think that the free market is
in many ways a great thing so for one
news day at least the giant squids of
anger are going to stop screaming about
Hell I'm a left-wing communist and start
screaming about how I'm a right-wing
fascist off topic but hey do you
remember that ban the left-wing fascist
that we liked when we were kids they
were awesome
right if it okay let's say you have a
dollar and let's say you decide to spend
that dollar buying fabric and thread
needles and whatever else you need to
build a puppy sized elephant costume for
a puppy then you sell the puppy sized
elephant costume for five dollars you go
out you buy enough fabric for five
costumes which you sell for $25 giving
you enough money to make 25 costumes
which is sell for under $25 and so on
until you're rich at least until you
lose all your money in the great
basement flood of 2009 although then
thanks to the free market you'll be able
to get competing bids from multiple
contractors so that's solving your
basement problem while it will cost you
so much money that the only way to cope
will be to dress your puppy up as an
elephant will be as cheap and efficient
as possible anyway capitalism isn't
actually that simple because the actual
functioning of capitalism is based on
debt in the real world you probably
won't be able to scale up the production
of your puppy sized elephant business
without at some point borrowing money
maybe you don't have the dollar you need
to build the first costume or maybe you
need money to build a highly automated
factory that will produce puppy-sized
elephant costumes cheaper and more
efficiently at some point you will have
to borrow money which you'll have to pay
back with interest but if your business
idea is a good one like say elephant
costumes for puppies or say penicillin
you'll be able to pay back the loan
interest and still make a profit and the
weird thing about that is when loan
capital flows freely wealth gets created
now of course an unregulated free market
can also lead to decreased economic
activity like say if the site of a puppy
in an elephant costume is so transfixing
that people who own such costumes find
it impossible to leave their houses in
order to go to work which is basically
what heroin is illegal but that's
another story
the story today is that on average
people who live in countries with freer
markets get richer over time because
those markets create wealth
that's why microfinance works through
websites like kiva.org link in the
doobly-doo people like me are able to
loan money to entrepreneurs in the
developing world who live on less than a
dollar a day and then those people get
at the capital to start a small business
and then pay me back with the revenue
that business generates loaning money to
poor entrepreneurs almost never cost the
lender anything the loans are repaid 99%
of the time so you can loan the same
twenty-five dollars over and over and
over again and you get to watch the free
market work and it does work Hank money
can't buy love but it can buy longer
healthier more secure lives and ale
fitting puppy costumes it's an amazing
feeling to watch these tiny wounds bring
people out of poverty all over the world
and because it's a loan and they repay
me it doesn't even cost me anything so
Hank that's Willy's defense of the free
market nerdfighters if you want to see a
made of awesome free market in action
you can go to kiva.org and Hank I'll see
you on Tuesday